BIND?
FIRST, HOLLYWOOD DISCOVERS
AMERICA.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
♪ ♪
ON THE SURFACE, ROSEANNE BARR
SEEMS LIKE AN UNLIKELY
CONSERVATIVE SUPERHERO, BUT
THERE SHE WAS LAST NIGHT,
REVIVING HER EPONYMOUS TV SHOW
THAT WENT OFF THE AIR 20 YEARS
AGO.
NOW, SHE IS PLAYING HER OLD
CHARACTER, AT THIS TIME AS A
TRUE BLUE TRUMPSTER DEALING WITH
A FAMILY MEMBER.
>> I KNOW SO MANY FAMILIES THAT
ARE DIVIDED OVER THE ELECTION
STILL, AND THEY STILL ARE
FIGHTING AND STUFF, SO WE WANTED
TO SHOW THAT AND HOW OUR FAMILY
IT DEALS WITH IT, AND WE ALL
HAVE THE HOPE THAT PEOPLE WILL
START TALKING TO EACH OTHER
AGAIN, BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT WE
NEED.
>> Laura: DID YOU SEE JOY
BEHAR'S FACE?
SHE WASN'T BUYING THAT AT ALL.
WHEN THE ORIGINAL SITCOM
"ROSEANNE" DEBUTED, THINK ABOUT
THIS, REAGAN WAS FINISHING HIS
LAST YEAR IN OFFICE, AND THE
NINE SEASONS LATER, BILL CLINTON
WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF HIS SECOND
TERM IN OFFICE.
OH, MY GOODNESS, HOW THINGS HAVE
CHANGED FOR AMERICA IN THE
INTERIM.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, IT DIDN'T
SURPRISE ME ONE BIT.
I THINK WE PREDICTED IT LAST
WEDNESDAY ON THE "ANGLE" WHEN
THE RATINGS CAME IN ENSURING
ROSEANNE HAD ABSOLUTELY CRUSHED
IT, NABBING 18 MILLION VIEWERS
WITH THE DEBUT.
THAT'S AWESOME.
NOW, FOR YEARS, THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY HAS MOVED
EVER FURTHER TO THE LEFT,
PUMPING OUT FILMS AND TELEVISION
SERIES THAT OFTEN OFFEND OR THEY
JUST SIMPLY DON'T RESONATE WITH
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WITH A
SLIGHTLY MORE TRADITIONAL
SENSIBILITY.
AND IT'S PRODUCERS PUSH THE
ENVELOPE ON POLITICAL ISSUES AND
DEPICTIONS, EVEN DURING THE
SO-CALLED FAMILY HOURS ON
TELEVISION.
WELL, THEY MAY HAVE CREATE SOME
FAVOR WITH THE VIEWERS ON THE
COAST, BUT I AM TELLING YOU,
THEY LOST MANY OTHERS.
AND THE PEOPLE THEY LOST?
THEY NEEDED A REASON TO RETURN
TO BROADCAST TELEVISION.
AND LAST NIGHT, "ROSEANNE" GAVE
IT TO THEM.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE LONG WONDERED
WHY THE DECISION-MAKERS IN
HOLLYWOOD HADN'T SEEN THE
WRITING ON THE WALL SOONER.
HOW IS IT GOOD BUSINESS TO
DELIVER GOOD CONTENT THAT, RIGHT
OFF THE BAT, HALF OF THE COUNTRY
IS GOING TO BE REPELLED BY?
MEMBER, 14 YEARS AGO,
MEL GIBSON'S "PASSION OF THE
CHRIST," ITS PREMIER AND
ULTIMATELY RACKED UP OVER
$600 MILLION IN TOTAL DOMESTIC
AND FOREIGN BOX OFFICE.
EVANGELICALS AND CATHOLICS
FLOCKED TO THE FILM OVER THE
EASTER WEEKEND, MANY SEEING IT
MORE THAN ONE TIME.
IT WAS AN ABSOLUTE TOUR THE
FORCE.
SO ONE WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT
THE INDUSTRY WOULD HAVE SEEN
THAT SUCCESS AND TRIED TO
REPLICATE IT, BUT THEY DIDN'T
REALLY DO THAT.
IT WAS ALMOST AS IF THE
ENTERTAINMENT EXECUTIVES FORCE
THEMSELVES TO LOOK AT THE OTHER
WAY AND WRITE OFF CONSERVATIVE
SUCCESS IN THEIR WORLD AS SOME
KIND OF STRANGE ANOMALY.
BUT ROSEANNE BARR TOOK THE
AUDIENCE SERIOUSLY, AND SHE WAS
WILLING TO REFLECT WHO THEY ARE
FAIRLY, EVEN THEIR POLITICS.
>> I THINK THE VOICE OF WORKING
PEOPLE IS ABSENT FROM TELEVISION
PEOPLE IS ABSENT FROM TELEVISIO
TELEVISION, AND I THINK WE
ALWAYS HAD THAT, AND WE HAVE IT
AGAIN, AND THERE'S NOTHING ON
TELEVISION LIKE IT.
IT REMINDS ME A LOT OF WHEN WE
FIRST STARTED, THERE WAS NOTHING
ON TELEVISION LIKE OUR SHOW, AND
IT'S STILL THAT WAY.
>> Laura: SHE IS A TRUE
INNOVATOR.
AND ROSEANNE SHOWS US THAT TRUMP
VOTERS, THEY ARE NOT MONSTERS,
THEY ARE NOT DEPLORABLE FOR OS,
AND, NO, THEY ARE NOT STUPID.
THEY ARE REAL PEOPLE WITH THE
REAL JAMES WHO GET INTO REAL
FIGHTS AND THEY GRAPPLE WITH
HEALTH CRISES AND MONEY TROUBLES